Sommerzeit ist Oldtimerzeit.
Die Beliebtheit alter Autos
hat in Deutschland
seit 2008 deutlich zugenommen,
und das merkt man auch im
Oldtimerclub Rhein-Erft.
Innerhalb von neun Jahren stieg die Zahl
der Wagen mit einem H-Kennzeichen
in ganz Deutschland um
fast eine Viertelmillion.
Das heutige Treffen richtet sich aber
nicht nur an die Oldtimerbesitzer selbst,
sondern wird zu einem Familienausflug,
getreu dem Motto „Fahren mit Freunden“.
Aufbruchsstimmung: Oldtimer nach
Oldtimer rollt vom Hof
und macht sich auf den Weg
zum gemeinsamen Picknick.
Zwischen Rolls-Royce,
BMW und Mercedes
gibt es auch so manche
Raritäten zu bestaunen.
So auch dieser Porsche 356 Speedster.
Er war das erste Serienfahrzeug,
das die Zuffenhausener hergestellt haben.
Aber nicht nur die seltenen
Autos glänzen hier.
In der Kolonne gibt es viele
Fahrzeuge, auf die sich ein Blick lohnt.
Da der Club nicht markengebunden ist,
ergibt sich eine Modellpalette,
die man in dieser Zusammenstellung
nicht oft sehen kann.
Rund fünf Jahrzehnte
der Automobilgeschichte
fahren hier durch kleine Dörfer
und über Landstraßen.
Bis die gesamte Kolonne
am Ziel ankommt.
Hier dürfen die Oldies eine
Verschnaufpause einlegen.
Fahrer und Mitfahrer sorgen
unterdessen für ihr leibliches Wohl.
Auch Manfred Büschel ist mit seinem Rolls-
Royce Silvercloud aus dem Jahr 1962 dabei.
Solche Ausfahrten machen wir zweimal
im Jahr, und das ist einfach Tradition.
Das Schönste an solchen Ausfahrten
sieht man grad hinter mir:
Das ist die Gemeinschaft. Man sitzt
zusammen, man unterhält sich,
man teilt das Essen,
jeder bringt was mit.
Und man spricht über Autos,
man spricht über Gott und die Welt.
Und das baut einen auf, wenn man
vielleicht ’ne harte Arbeitswoche hatte
oder ’ne anstrengende Dienstreise
oder – das „harte“ Rentnerleben.
Auch Dirk Röttgen nimmt mit seinem
50 Jahre alten Mercedes 250 SL
an der Ausfahrt teil und genießt
besonders die gemeinsamen Picknicks.
[Die] sind schon sehr wichtig, weil die
einfach die Gemeinschaft fördern, im Club.
Ich mein, wir kennen uns
alle Male untereinander,
aber es sind immer Erlebnisse, die
vergisst man ja so schnell auch nicht.
Wir haben ja alle ’nen Tick, würde ich mal
so sagen, und das sind halt Oldtimer.
Andere sammeln Uhren
oder irgendwas anderes.
Ob Sammelleidenschaft, Hobby
oder Kindheitserinnerungen –
die Liebe zu Oldtimern führt die
unterschiedlichsten Menschen zusammen.
Bei den Erwartungen an das Treffen
setzt jeder andere Schwerpunkte.
Ja, zuhause ist das dann oft so, dass
das Verständnis nicht immer so da ist,
wenn man so viel über
die Autos quatscht,
und unter den Clubkameraden
kann’s eigentlich nie genug sein.
Von daher, da kann man
sich gut austauschen.
Dagmar Puritz hat sich heute lieber
zum Picknick fahren lassen
und genießt das Zusammensein mit
den anderen Clubkameraden
und vor allem auch deren Begleiterinnen.
Zusammen zu essen und quatschen
zu können, auch über andere Themen
für Frauen zumindest, was nicht
mit Auto zu tun hat.
Letztlich geht es im Oldtimerclub
Rhein-Erft einfach um das Zusammenleben
rund um die alten Schätze. Schließlich
ist regelmäßige Bewegung ein Muss.
Je älter die Autos, umso öfter ist
was dran – und vor allen Dingen:
Sie müssen ja auch mal bewegt werden,
und dann kommt auch schon mal was dran.
Wenn man sie nicht bewegt,
kommt noch mehr dran,
denn dann stehen sie sich kaputt.
Und so ein Oldtimerclub, der bietet auch
die Möglichkeit, dass man Leute trifft,
die die gleichen Probleme haben und die
Lösungen wissen. Da findet man Hilfe.
Der Besitz eines Oldtimers
bedeutet also viel mehr,
als nur ein schönes Auto
sein Eigen zu nennen.
In einem Oldtimerclub wird man
Teil einer Gesellschaft –
und auch einer kleinen Oldtimerfamilie.